we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a voicemail from someone who i
sympathize with in terms of the feeling
that they have but we always want to
remain realistic and pragmatic take a
listen hey David this is Mike from
Indiana I just got a comment they should
do the use of twenty-fifth amendment
with kick Trump out of office and he
should go directly to prison like
because my opinion he's responsible for
a murder of all these cases at Toronto
Fire stop solving yeah so listen I
understand the frustration in our
country even if you're removed from the
presidency for being unfit you don't go
to elect directly to prison we need
indictments we have due process here in
this country all that stuff but I get
the frustration and there's no doubt
that Trump is not fit to serve but
here's the reality we all just need to
come to ok the opportunity to remove
Trump comes in six and a half months and
it will be when we vote in November
everybody's got a vote in November so
it's time for everybody it's time for
the Green Party centrist Democrats
disaffected Republicans former Bernie
supporter everybody's got to come
together because impeachments not going
to remove him 20 2015 2 remove him
none of these mechanisms are going to
work we have been saying it since before
the results of the Moller probe were
published nothing has changed we are
down to six and a half months and it's
crazy because for three years we've been
saying the same thing he deserves to be
removed but he's not going to and the
opportunity will be November of 2020 we
said it two years ago we said it one
year ago we are six and a half months
away it's mid April early November is
when this happens that's the way to do
it get your frustration out by voting in
November ideally a via absentee ballot
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen a lot of those decisions will be
made at the state level and I'll talk
about that on the Friday show during
audience questions but that is the most
important thing that we can do because
these other mechanisms aren't going to
we're all seeing front-and-center the
disaster through his dealing of corrode
with coronavirus that this presidency
has been it should be the last straw the
straw that broke the camel's back
whatever metaphor you want to use and
we've got a vote in November that's it
the left has to come together we can't
be divided we have a great bonus show
for you today
Florida's totally Smurfs like a governor
Ron de santis has determined that
professional wrestling is an essential
business is an essential business during
the pandemic a court has thrown out
Donald Trump's rollbacks of school
nutrition rules you may not even have
known that he was doing this a court has
thrown it out and we have more and more
people protesting in their cars because
they can't safely march in their streets
I will talk about that and so much more
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we've got the show we've got
the bonus show and then later today most
evenings we have the live stream of the
White House coronavirus press briefing
join me for one join me for all of them
I'll see you then